What's up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. We're We're not
going to sugarcoat anything. We're going
to look at everything that the church
doesn't want to talk about, that people
think are controversial topics. We're
going to look at that stuff. And right
now we're going to look at is it crazy
to question mainstream media? When the
mainstream propagandist put things out
in the news, does it make you crazy or
insane or conspiracy theorist to
question what the mainstream media feeds
us? I don't think so. I think as
rational thinking, logical thinking
people, we need to look at what the
mainstream media puts out and say is it
true? There's a saying that says, "Don't
believe everything you hear and only
believe half of what you see." That
statement is becoming more true than we
could have ever imagined with AI and
just
deception beyond all belief.
Jesus said, "When the disciples and
everybody was asking, 'What will be the
signs of your coming?'" He said, "Let no
man deceive you. We're in the days of
deception."
So, I want to I want to just show why
I question things. Why I question
mainstream media. Why I question the
official story when this stuff comes
out. I'm not going to be specifically
addressing a recent event, but I have
questions. I I I see things and I'm
like, "Wait a minute. That doesn't seem
to add up, you know? How does a 20
20-year-old get into an event with a a a
weapon and the Secret Service doesn't
see him even when everybody's pointing
him out and
you know, how how can you get grazed by
an assault rifle bullet and still have
your ear intact? Why are you wearing a
bandage when you should have your ear
stitched up? I mean, you're supposed to
when you get stitches, I never had a
bandage. When
when you get a bandage, you're supposed
to take it off after a day or so to let
that air out. I I have questions. I
don't think it's wrong to ask questions.
I don't think it's crazy to ask
questions. I don't think it's
insensitive, any of these things. It's
It's very smart. It's an intelligent
thing to question everything. Scrutinize
everything.
I think we should all do that. I'm going
to show you a couple of things from the
past that were in mainstream media that
I have questions about. Reasons why I'm
so skeptical when it comes to big events
or mainstream media telling us things or
politics. All these things. Let's look
at some examples of why I question
things.
You're watching Candid Truth.
And we're going to be talking about fake
news. Do you believe in fake news? I
believe there is a such thing as fake
news.
So, one thing there I'm I'm going to try
to sugarcoat. I'm going to try to code
some of the things I say because I don't
want this video to get flagged. YouTube
censors everything. Google censors
everything. When you start questioning
things,
these topics get censored, taken down,
removed. I remember there was a time
when you could search YouTube and you
could search for these conspiracy
theories and there's all kinds of videos
out there. It was It was like a free
speech world, a free thinking world
where you could say, "Hey, yeah, that
that's right. That doesn't add up. Oh,
look at this video. I never thought
about that, but
yeah, that doesn't make sense."
And now those videos get scrubbed, they
get removed and they're called I don't
know, they're called dangerous.
Dangerous, you know, it's dangerous to
think these days.
So, one thing I thought was interesting
about this event, this what I'm not
going to say the name, but the event was
a a school and there were children that
were hurt and you know, they they died.
I'm trying to say this as as
coded as I can so that this thing
doesn't get pulled down, but you know
the event I'm talking about. Do I'm
showing you pictures of two events here.
One was in Colorado and it happened at a
Batman movie and this guy came in with a
gun at a Batman movie. Now, the other
side on the right side, you see two
parents of children victims at this
school where there was a a gunman that
came in.
Now, look at that woman.
The woman in the picture who's the
mother of
of one of the victims looks just like
the lawyer of the shooter at the Batman
event.
Am I crazy? Am I crazy for thinking that
they look the same?
Now, there are there are such thing as
these actors. I won't say this term
either because this term will get
flagged, but in these crisis, there's
these people that get hired and they get
hired to to help
do drills.
And when they do these drills, I believe
that these drills are getting recorded
and you know, that people do this They
do these jobs because they think they're
helping
um police do training and things like
that. And then these drills end up
getting aired on national television.
And are you going to believe some
uh
some crazy person from this small town
who says, "No, that was a drill. I was
in it." Or you going to believe the
giant of mainstream media, CNN, NBC,
ABC, every everything is is telling you
this is a real event. Are you going to
believe that or you going to believe
this one person that says, "I was there.
I know it was a drill." Right? So, these
events could be recorded and put on TV
and and told to us as real. That's not
crazy to think about. Do we trust our
government? Do we trust politicians? Do
we trust the the
the leaders of this country or any other
country? Which one was trustworthy? Was
it Hitler? Was it Stalin? Was it
Pharaoh? I mean, none of our leaders
have been trustworthy. And I have these
conversations with people all the ti-
all the time and they say, "Look, I
don't trust my government."
Well, how come when I question it, you
think I'm crazy? Or they say, "I don't I
don't believe everything I see on TV."
Well, how come when I point out these
inconsistencies,
you get triggered or you say I'm crazy
or tin foil hat conspiracy theorist.
How can you say you don't trust the
media, you don't trust politics, but
then it's crazy to question it. It
doesn't It doesn't add up. I think it's
just cognitive dissonance. So, this is
just one interesting thing I I've seen
because I think this lady is one of
these people that get hired at these
drills and things.
So then we see this father. And this
father is the victim or he's the father
of a victim and he lost his daughter the
very day before. Just mere hours ago. 24
hours ago maybe. He lost his daughter.
Now, look how he reacts when he comes on
to do this um
this interview on national television
and he he's smiling and he's laughing
and he says, "Are we ready to start? Or
are we ready to begin?"
And then he gets into character. Watch
this.
Assume he's going to come out to the
microphones now
and make a statement. Uh looks like the
family is there
and they're getting ready to make uh to
come to the microphone, so we'll listen
now.
Are we ready to start?
So, my name's Robbie Parker.
My family is one of the families that
lost a child yesterday
in the Sandy Hook Elementary School
shootings here in Connecticut.
So, he just lost his daughter yesterday.
Look, I'm not trying to be insensitive.
I'm If this really happened, I'm so
terribly heartbroken for this man. But
there's We're going to see that there's
a lot of questionable things that
happened at this event. Things that
don't line up with what the mainstream
media official story said. And when I
see all the evidence that things aren't
lining up and then I see a guy who just
lost his daughter yesterday and he says
he's laughing,
you know, I don't I get it. You can go
on with your life maybe in in within
hours.
But why is he getting into character?
Why is he like
Okay, uh
I love And there's no no tear, not a
single tear. So, why even put on the
act? If If you're really like already
doing that well, why don't you just get
up there and say, "Hey, you know what?
My daughter I lost my daughter
yesterday." And just be real with it.
Why put on the act?
All right, let's let's continue.
You guys let me know in the comments. I
want to know what you think.
So, Anderson Cooper
Cooper Anderson, Anderson Cooper, I
can't remember his name. Anderson
Cooper, I think. Cooper Anderson.
Anyway,
he is at this supposedly he is at the
funeral home of victims of this event.
Said event, this school event.
And when he turns his head,
I want to I want to say something to
you.
When he turns his head sideways,
his nose
his nose disappears.
I work with green screen. I know how
green screen works. I've seen the
glitches.
I've never turned my head sideways and
move like this and my nose disappear
with a real background.
Now, he turns his head sideways and his
nose gets cut off
as if he's on a green screen.
I'm just
I'm just looking at stuff. I'm I'm
seeing things. I'm not making any I'm
not trying I don't want to believe that
this is a a
an actor, a drill. I don't want to
believe that. But I I can't lie to
myself when I see what I see. If I was
watching a Hollywood movie and I saw a
dude's nose get cut off, I would say,
"Man, that was terrible editing."
And I I question it. I I would I would
see it. I would recognize it. I'd point
it out. Now, I'm going to do the same
here and watch this.
Is there anything else you want to say?
His nose is gone.
For multiple frames, his nose is gone.
Look at that.
It's going to show it a couple times.
His nose just disappears.
Here it is. Nose gone.
Did you see that? It It's not just me,
right? It's not just my eyes playing
tricks on me.
I'm just looking at evidence here. We're
looking Okay, so
father that
is laughing and then kind of gets into
character.
Nose disappears when you're at a funeral
as if you're on a green screen.
Um the mother looks like she's the same
woman as a as a lawyer in Denver
at another event. Let's keep going.
Let's Let's see what's next.
So, as you can see here, the nose is
missing completely. Half his nose is
gone.
Now, this guy, do you see anything
interesting in this picture? For one,
this guy says that he was at his house
and the event happened and two children
were sitting on his lawn saying, "Our
teacher's dead
and we can't go back to the school. Our
teacher's dead." And he came out and he
offered the kids uh juice and cookies
and and he called their parents. He
didn't call the cops, which is strange.
Some people said I I didn't I was
putting this stuff together. It's taking
too long. I just want to get this
message out there.
But apparently, he was actually in the
event. Like you you you can see videos
where he's at the school in the event,
yet he's saying, "I was just sitting at
my house and these kids left the school,
were sitting on my lawn." So, that
doesn't add up. But notice something
interesting on a sign in the background.
Everyone must check in. Why is there a
you know, it takes time to bring in one
of these glowing signs like this, type
in the message, "Everyone must check
in." Check in the what? What What are
they checking into? This is why people
think that this might be a drill.
There's There's interesting things.
You're going to see There's really
interesting things, but I didn't even
put some of it in here.
Some of it was like all the students and
parents that were around were wearing
these lanyards, these colored lanyards,
and there was like water bottles at the
feet of the police officers, like
they've been
on the set of a movie waiting to shoot.
Everyone must check in to what? This is
a
an event This is a crisis. Like I'm
trying not to say the words, but like an
active
you know,
crisis.
Now, here we see kids lining up in the
top left corner. You see a a police
officer escorting kids away from the
school. Now, this isn't a traumatic
event, right? The Like things are going
down and she's hustling them out of the
way. But then when you see another
angle, these other two pictures, why do
you see parents just standing there with
their arms folded watching?
How come the kids are in different
orders? But if you notice this kid in
the front here with the kind of mohawk
hair, uh he's got a blond hair in this
black shirt and blue jeans. In this
other picture, he's he's right here,
circled in red. He's in the back of the
line now.
So, all the kids are out of order like
like this was take two.
And the parents are just watching arms
folded.
I got questions.
What's happening here?
Now, in this This is very interesting
because this was a helicopter view
of of the event going down and you just
see people aimlessly walking around.
Whoever made this video is pointing at
the at the people of how they go around
the building and they come back through.
It's just one big circle.
It's like
um a director said, "Hey, I just need
everybody just walk around the building
and come through the building and walk
out the door." But pay attention that
dude in the yellow.
This dude in the yellow right here Look
at him. He's walking towards a wall
right now. And then he he stops and
turns this way. Oh, wait. I wasn't
supposed to go to the wall. I was
supposed to walk this way. And so, he's
walking.
And now he's over here and he's
aimlessly walking this way.
Notice this this kid in the yellow.
Look, he's walking this way. Where is he
going? He He has nowhere to go.
Aimlessly walking with his hands in his
pockets.
And so, when you pay attention, you'll
see that everyone is walking around the
building and re-entering. They're
re-entering right here. Look at this.
They're coming back in through the
building
and out the building.
What's going on here to
Is that crazy to point that out?
This is This is so mind-boggling to me.
I don't know if everybody has seen this
stuff. You know, this is kind of old to
me. I've I've been watching this kind of
stuff since 2012. Since 2012, God opened
my eyes and I never could see the world
the same again. I've seen
uh symbolism in cartoons and man,
cartoons are pushing agendas and
witchcraft and LGBTQ and all this stuff
and satanic symbols.
And it was like every time I saw a major
event, not every time, but there were
certain times that like as soon as I saw
it, I was like, "Wait a minute. This
just looks staged."
And and people are like, "Well, where's
your evidence? You're making You're just
saying stuff. You're saying stuff
without seeing anything." But I can't
explain it. It's like watching wrestling
and saying, "This looks fake to me."
What Where's my evidence? I don't know.
When he hit him, it didn't look real,
you know. Yeah, there's blood, but
I don't know. It just doesn't make
sense.
God has given me eyes to see. He's given
me discernment and now I don't see the
world the same way and I question
things, things I never questioned
before. I was never a conspiracy
theorist. I thought those people were
crazy because the media makes them look
crazy. And notice any movie or TV show
you watch and somebody starts bringing
up some kind of theory like that,
everybody looks around like, "Oh, yeah,
he's nuts, you know. He's lost it."
But it They're making it like the media
also, movies and shows and cartoons and
everything, make it look um
dumb. Like like make it look like you
don't want to be smart. To be smart is
uncool. You're like Steve Urkle. No, you
want to be like Beavis and Butthead.
They're cool, right?
But smart, no. You get shoved in the
locker, made fun of, nerdy glasses. You
know what I'm saying? This is propaganda
to say it's not cool to be smart.
And actually, you you just want to Your
mission in life is to go to that party,
get drunk, get laid, and and now you're
cool.
Just tune out, turn your brain off.
That's what makes you cool, right?
That's what the media says. And then
when you question things, you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist.
All right.
So, one interesting thing that anybody
can do, the website for this school is
listed at the bottom. Now, you can use
this website called the Wayback Machine
and it's web.archive.org.
And when you look, notice there's a
little bit of activity 2001 through
2007,
there's activity even in even in
slightly in 2008 because, you know,
people are going there to look at the
schedule. When When was that field trip?
What is What's on the lunch menu today?
Um what was my kids' homework? They're
looking at the website. But then from
most of 2008 to 2012,
there is not a single visit, not one. It
That website is dead.
And you know what? People say they think
that that school was shut down for
asbestos.
That they didn't allow
anything to go on in that school because
it was shut down. And then notice look,
activity because this thing happened
This event happened in December 2012.
And look, activity in 2013 because now
people are interested. They're looking
it up. What happened at this school? And
there's all this activity after that.
Isn't this interesting
that there was zero activity
at that school during the during those
years?
I got questions.
We can't just turn a blind eye to this
stuff. We're building up the case.
There's a mountain of evidence going
This is why I question mainstream media.
This is why I question politics. This is
why I believe there's an agenda to take
away guns. How come every single time
there's an event or a crisis,
the
man, I don't know what words I can say.
The shooter
ends up dead. Every time.
He's dead. Not Not brought in for
questioning. What was your motive? How
did you get in? No questions can be
asked. He's dead. Every time. Every
event I can think of.
And And so, there's no There's no case
closed. It's it. It's done.
So,
one of the kids was questioned on this
talk show about what happened and the
kid literally says it was a drill.
And you know, you might can say, "Look,
man, he's a kid. He's nervous. He He
just said something that didn't make
sense." But okay, if this video was the
only thing out there that would that
didn't make sense, then okay.
But he's adding to the mountain of
evidence, right? Listen to what he says.
He says, "We were We were hiding under
our desk. It was a drill. We were hiding
under our desk." Louie, want me to ask
you what you remembered from that day?
Yes.
I remember that a lot
a lot of policemen were in the um school
um
[snorts]
Well, a lot I was like
like I'm under when it when we were
having a drill we were hiding under like
Can I listen to it again? when it when
we were having a like I'm under when it
when we were having a drill
We were hiding under He's about to say
we're hiding under the desk. When we
were having a drill, we were hiding
under the desk. Like I'm under when it
when we were having a drill we were
hiding under like
Take your time. There's no hurry. Go
ahead. Let me ask you What What would
you like to say to your teachers?
He's asking the kid what happened that
day. He's not saying, "Hey, you remember
one time a long time ago when you had a
drill?"
What happened that day?
And the kid says, "When we're hiding
under the desk when we're having a
drill, we were hiding under the desk."
I'm just asking questions here. What
drill is he talking about?
What's he talking about?
All right. Let's look at some more
evidence.
So, there's a great documentary. You
can't get it on YouTube, of course, but
go to BitChute or Rumble and look up
Sophia. I don't even know if I'll get
shut down for saying her name. Small
storm.
I'll separate the name. It's at the
bottom written down there. She made this
in 2013,
you know, months after the event
happened. It's called Unraveling and the
words are on the screen. I'm not going
to say the words.
You watch that documentary. It's just
over an hour. She's got damning evidence
piled up that you get you have to
you have to ask questions if you have a
logical thinking mind, rational thinking
mind, you have to question these things.
Now, there was another
another event that happened in Or- in
Orlando at a nightclub called Pulse.
It's on the screen. Again, I'm trying
not to say these words in like a
coherent sentence because I don't want
AI to flag this video and pull it down,
but there was an event at a place
called Pulse in Orlando
and uh some things went down there.
Now, I'm showing you pictures of the
sign because I want you to see what the
logo looks like. Notice this pink sign
with a P in a circle, a glowing sign,
because there's some interesting things
that happened during
the news footage here.
Notice they're walking this guy. He's
injured. What is happening right here?
What is this?
Didn't Didn't this thing just happen in
the club? And now you have the cop and
someone else helping escort him
back towards the club?
Okay, that that's strange. Maybe he's
just one guy. Maybe he's one guy that
happened to get that far down the road
and now they're walking him back to the
ambulance. I don't know, but it happens
again.
See, look at this guy. They're carrying
this guy. He's shot in the leg and
they're taking him back towards There is
the pink sign. Back to the Pulse.
Everyone is making their way back
towards the club that that this event
happened at.
Where the thing went down. Like why
would you go back to that place?
And why are there
why are there sit- civilians helping
other civilians? There's There's You see
the cops everywhere. They're at at both
ends. There's like 30 cops there. And
ambulances and everything. Why are the
civilians the ones helping?
Now, in this clip, you're going to see
something really interesting because
when they carry this guy they end up
setting him on the ground and he's
standing up like nothing's even wrong.
And his friend's like, you know, they're
looking back.
Watch this. They're carrying him. We
just saw him He He got shot in the leg
with a
an assault rifle.
His leg is shattered. But they're
standing him up. He ain't got no
problems. And now this friend of his
ends up turning to the camera giving a
thumbs up. Look, right here. He smiles
and gives a thumbs up at the camera
like, "Yep, I did it. We did it. We
carried him down and we're on TV."
Check me out.
Like
is that not strange?
Are these not strange things?
Okay, so when I see events where it's
like
Yep, somebody came in and he used this
type of weapon.
All the time. It's always this
type of weapon, this assault type
weapon, and there's always
things being said after that. Like we
need to take these things away.
Right? Look, I don't even own one. I
don't even own a gun. But I still
believe in the freedom to own one, to
protect yourself, to protect your
family.
When you start saying disarm the
citizens
that's when bad things follow. I don't
trust that. I don't like And especially
when you see that the the the official
story doesn't line up, there's strange
things, people wandering around in
circles around the school, people
acting, people doing all these things,
and then they start saying, "Yeah, you
know what? We need to get rid of these
things." I'm trying not to say certain
words, guys.
All right.
Let's watch this clip. So, I don't know
how, but by the glory of God, he shoots
towards my head, but it hits my hand. It
hits his hand.
And then he shoots me again and it hits
the side of my hip.
All right.
Minutes later, he was shot a fourth time
in the hand and a fifth in his left hip.
CBS. Colon said the gunman shot a girl
next to him and then aimed for his head,
but somehow only shot his hand and his
hip. He only hit Angel in the hand and
hip. Another bullet struck his hip and a
third hit his leg.
Oh, "But the bullet hit his hand," Colon
said. The gunman aimed at Colon's head,
but wound up shooting him in the hand.
hand
Then he shot Colon in the hip.
Look at his hand.
Which hand? He's in the hospital room
right now. Which hand was shot?
By an assault rifle.
Or any kind of gun.
Which hand?
His hand is not in a you know
Trump got grazed and he's wearing a
bandage.
This guy got shot in the hand and he's
fully functional. His fingers are
moving. He's There's not a single thing.
He's not wearing a brace, not a cast,
not a
not a bandage.
He got shot in the hand over and over.
He said it. Somebody even called.
Somebody found the number to the
hospital. Called and said, "I want to
talk to Angel." And I won't say the name
because I don't know what words are
getting flagged here.
He said the guy's name. They put him
through and he said, "Hey, you remember
me?" He didn't know the guy. He just
said, "Hey, remember me from high
school?" And he's like, "Uh I don't
know." And he's like, "Remember the hat
thing from high school?" Just trying to
lead him on. He says, "Man, what
happened? Where Where'd you get shot?"
And he said, "In my hip and in my hand."
He was saying it again.
But there seems to be no injury to the
hand.
Just asking questions, man.
So, there is an amazing documentary
called The Great American Psyopera. You
can't get it on YouTube. You have to go
to BitChute or Rumble. This thing is 4
hours long. He leaves no stone unturned.
I already questioned the narrative and I
and I already believed it was
an inside thing, but when I watched
this, it blew my mind. It took it to the
next level where it's like
some of this stuff was photoshopped.
Some of this stuff was
layered in with
video editing programs. Man, I I really
don't like having to censor my own
words,
but you guys I think you guys are
following along. So, check out this
documentary. These are actually scenes
from the documentary.
And so,
I want you to question things.
There were people that were interviewed.
There were people on the streets right
after it happened. News camera man right
up in their face and say, "What
happened?" And they said, "It was a
bomb." And they said, "Bomb? We heard it
was a plane." They said, "No, no, no
plane. Bomb."
There was firemen that said it We It was
right above our heads. It was like boom
boom boom. It was a bomb.
Like there were people who were there
who were not paid actors. They weren't
news people and they said it was a bomb.
They denied the fact that there was
planes. I'm just going to throw that out
there because you're going to see some
eye-opening stuff here that's really
crazy. And I remember
I make videos for a living. I make
documentaries. I I use After Effects. I
use these special effects programs,
green screen, all this stuff. I know how
this stuff works. When I look at this, I
see exactly what's going on and I'm
like, "Whoa, this is impossible to be
real." This is This has And you're going
to see. You'll be able to see it, too.
Check it out.
Only three 9/11 airplane videos are
confirmed to have been shown live. ABC
Chopper 7,
Fox Chopper 5, and WPIX.
Okay.
So, at this event, there were only three
footages that were live at the time.
Everything else was shown the next day
or hours later or something. But the
only the only footage Okay, this is what
I'm going to say. The only footage that
was live that caught a plane entering
into a building were three.
And there's something very unique about
all three of these footages and we're
going to find out what it is.
Notice
the sky is supposed to be like really
bright blue. Like these are these are
news crew camera. They have great high
high dollar top quality cameras.
Why is this look so white? It almost
looks black and white.
This is purposefully done. This is when
you when you get a camera out, you have
to adjust the settings to make it
uh you know, adjust to the the ISO
settings and all this to the lighting.
And this was purposefully done where it
was over contrasted where it's literally
like black against white. And this is
this is too. This is not natural blue
sky. This is
faded. This is hazy.
And you're going to see why it's done
that way.
So all the live shots had something in
common. They were all high contrast
between the the tower and the sky. So
the tower is dark and the sky is really
light or white even.
There's no panning or tilting or
zooming. So all three of these live
footages just happen to be tripod shot.
They weren't handheld. They weren't
moving.
All of them were
they show an airplane path
across the sky only.
And it shows an airplane disappears
across the straight edge meaning the
straight edge of the building.
And the   impact wall
was hidden. So they're they're shooting
it on the opposite side of the impact.
So you're not actually seeing like
uh a third-person view of a plane
entering into a building. You're seeing
it like you're behind the building and
you're seeing the plane coming from the
other side.
And there were no shadows required.
Meaning on the building.
So here he's going to break it down what
you can do with the footage like that.
Why you need high contrast really light
sky dark building
because it you're going to do a method
called keying and you can do it live.
Notice you know, think about graphics on
live footage. When you're a newscaster,
you can put your name at the bottom. You
can put scrolling text. All that's done
live. This is graphics live.
Think about the stuff we have now. We
got Snapchat where you can have glasses
on. You can have a wig on. All that
stuff's fake and it's tracking your face
live. Now this was a long time ago. I'm
not saying it's that advanced, but I'm
saying it's so easy to put
a graphic on a live video. Especially if
it's just an image of a plane entering
into the screen and then
hitting a dark object. Check it out. In
video, a key is an effect that makes
part of a video transparent based on
some property like color or brightness.
So he's explaining right now.
Notice this black area.
This is now transparent.
This
This is a building as a top layer. So
this what that means is
you could put a graphic of an airplane
and it would actually go behind this
building because this is transparent.
You would see the airplane
and then suddenly it would go behind
this building because the building is
the top layer.
It's the top layer and all of this is
transparent.
So this is how this is how this could
have been done. And I'm going to show
you evidence to to prove to you that it
was done this way.
Notice that when the two layers are back
together, it looks identical to the
original.
Remember, it's actually two layers
stacked up.
To complete the illusion, the airplane
layer is sandwiched in between the other
two.
Presto.
If the airplane goes too far, oops, it
looks like it comes out the backside.
So you know,
the dark image. I don't know if this
makes sense to people. I To me it just
makes sense because I do I do Photoshop
and Premiere and all this.
But
all of the white is transparent and
these black boxes are on top. So if this
plane were to go too far, it would look
like it popped out the other side, but
that's not possible, right? Because
these buildings are made out of
steel.
Like steel beams on the inside it's it's
layers. It's not like a a hollow
cardboard box. It's layers and layers.
There's rooms and cubicles and
it it's steel beams, concrete, all that.
It doesn't just pop out the other side
unfazed. You realize that planes are
made out of aluminum. The nose of that
thing is hollow plastic.
I'm I'm going to show you evidence that
shows you that those noses can't even
withstand a duck hitting it or birds
hitting it.
So how in the world could
the nose of that plane pop out the other
side? It's it's physically impossible.
Check this out.
A mask can be drawn on the airplane
layer.
The South Tower is in the center of the
frame. The left half of the screen is
masked off. The airplane goes in and we
never see it again.
So what he's saying is halfway down the
screen it's not transparent. This side
of the screen is now not transparent. So
when that plane goes behind this layer
it doesn't pop out the other side
because it's hidden by this layer on
top. I hope that makes sense because
this guy put so much graphical like
illustration just to show you how it
works. You know, people like us that do
this all the time, we understand it
anyway, but he broke it down.
So here he's going to show that the
the helicopter is like 5 miles away.
This the building's already smoking.
And yet this news crew is 5 miles away
and they're just now making their way to
it. But he's setting up the shot. His
camera is on a tripod. He's on a
helicopter, but helicopters are pretty
steady.
He and he's zooming in zooming in
zooming in and he has his shot ready and
then bam, he adds the composite. He adds
the key of the plane.
But
the helicopter does drift a little bit
and it drifts to the left making that
mask come undone and now you see the
nose of the plane pop out. When that
happens, this cameraman thinks fast and
he goes to black screen.
And then he comes right back. You're
going to see all that.
You look at the picture from our chopper
now arriving at the scene. What is he
talking about? Arriving at the scene?
The chopper is over the Hackensack River
in New Jersey, 5 miles away.
Why are they not headed toward what is
already the news story of the year?
Wait a minute. Is something missing
here?
With the camera zoomed in, now it looks
like the chopper is arriving at the
scene.
Seems that we weren't supposed to see
that wide shot. And that's because
there's no plane in it.
Notice in the wide shot.
He he's trying to get his camera ready
for this mask.
The mask is halfway down the screen.
He's zooming in zooming in zooming in,
but notice
there's no plane in the screen.
All this area and we're not seeing
anything flying into the screen and then
all of a sudden
when he gets into position
Now that would be simple to reverse
engineer that. You can literally reverse
that footage at the same rate of speed
and see where that plane should have
been in the screen. And he does that.
This guy breaks it down. I'm telling
you.
So here's where they're going to scale
it.
By adjusting the scale and position of
every video frame, matching the speed of
the airplane and working backwards,
we can determine where the plane should
be earlier.
The plane should be visible for over 5
seconds. That's 340 separate images.
And there is no plane.
So you see that, right? Like there
there's no plane there.
So
I I have to ask these questions. I'm
looking at the physics. I'm looking at
like
Okay, it it just sounds crazy to say
look on live television they composited
the plane, but why is it a tripod shot?
Why is there only three that are
catching this? You know, I get it. It
was a it was a live event.
Only three people caught it, but all of
them are on a tripod. All of them are
over contrasted to where it's black and
white. All of them are facing away from
the impact area.
And here in the wide shot, there's no
plane.
So you have to ask why? Why was there no
plane? Things are starting to add up.
But they're not adding up to what the
story was.
The nose of the airplane appears to pop
out the backside of the tower. Exactly
the problem that could occur with live
compositing.
So, what happened was he had the shot
ready. He this this cameraman had his
shot a money shot. But then as he was
sitting there waiting to add that
composite of the plane
the helicopter drifted just a bit to the
left or to the right actually to where
the middle mask wasn't there anymore and
the nose popped out the other side.
To which he goes straight to a black
screen after this.
How can a nose pop out undamaged?
Through layers and layers and layers of
metal and steel and concrete, it can't
happen.
Here's where the the mask is down the
middle of it. Now, watch how the
helicopter drifted and that's why you
see the nose. Helicopters cannot hold
still. They drift. [music]
The shot begins okay, but the camera
drifts far enough
[music]
so that the back edge of the tower is
now outside the mask area.
And then the camera goes black and then
it comes back. The cameraman reacted,
why is there black screen? Why does it
go black? Notice when it goes black, it
wasn't it wasn't the live feed cut out
because look, all the stuff is here on
the on the screen. You see all the
watermarks.
This was on the cameraman's side.
And so when he drifted, see this this
line right here should have been in the
center of this
building.
But because it drifted over here, now
you're actually seeing the nose pop out
and he has to react quick and go to
black screen and then come back to the
to the explosion.
Has anybody heard this stuff? Anybody
ever seen this stuff?
Is anybody like thinking, man, I never
even questioned this stuff, but now I'm
starting to ask questions. I believe we
need to ask questions.
Jesus said we're going to be living in
the most deceptive time in human
history. Now with AI and all these
things, you can fake a voice, you can
fake a video. I could literally take a
picture of my house and tell this
program, a free program Luna make my
house on fire and my house will be on
fire and I could tell the world that my
house caught on fire and I could start a
GoFundMe and I could make thousands of
dollars based on a lie, deception.
What
What kind of danger are we in when the
media has access to this type of
technology?
And and they're already doing it. I
believe that the deception has already
been happening for years.
Even as far back as the moon landing.
Don't get me started at how fake that
looked. How so many things did not add
up with that. So, as far back as '69 at
least they've been faking things in the
media and giving it to the public as
real.
Now, he's going to show you because
maybe somebody says, well maybe it's not
even a piece of maybe it's not the nose
of the plane. Maybe it's
uh you know, just some debris popping
out the other side. Well, he takes
frames from
this
you know, from the from the plane
entering into the screen, he cuts out
the frames and then he compares it to
Three of them are the nose of the
airplane before it goes into the
building.
Three are the nose coming out of the
Now, you can't even tell the difference
when he compares them all side by side,
they look identical. Why? Because it is.
Because that is the composite plane
popping out the other side that came out
the the mask that was never supposed to
be shown.
But people it's this is cognitive
dissonance. Nobody can ask that
question. Nobody will even believe that
there was no planes. They think, you
know, if anything, maybe there was some
you know, I don't know. Maybe they'll
question some part of the narrative.
But are we even questioning enough?
Honestly, it's like, whoa, it's way
deeper than we ever expected. Now,
listen to what these guys say.
Watch how the aircraft penetrates the
building.
Completely in one side and out the
other. Just To be sure there it is.
There it is. The plane went right
through
the other tower of the World Trade
Center.
So, these guys are are saying it.
They're saying, hey, that that plane
went through the building. But that's
not possible. We're going to show you
why not. Why is it not possible?
Because that nose is made out of
plastic. It's hollow. Check this out.
Not designed to withstand any sort of
collision. That nose cone there is is
made of plastic and it's very easily
indented. They think that a bird hit
that nose cone, which again is made of
plastic, it's hollow inside. It would
have had to go through two sets of steel
box columns. Which is obviously possible
because it happened. You know, whether
or not it can be sufficiently explained
is another issue. There's a lot of
things in life that can't be, you know,
fully explained.
So, that that footage of that newscaster
was not about this event. He's just
saying in general hey,
a plane had its nose crushed in by some
birds and he's saying he's explaining
what a plane's made out of. He's like,
that that nose is hollow plastic and
birds can literally punch it in. What
would layers and layers of steel and
concrete do to an aluminum plane? For
one,
those wings would have peeled straight
back.
It would have maybe the
the long cylindrical part would have
went in, but the wings would have went
peeled right back. Yet we see a hole in
the shape of a building like this is
some cartoon physics like Road Runner or
the coyote
you know, when he crashes through a rock
and you see every hair and everything.
It doesn't happen. That kind of that
stuff would have peeled right back, but
it didn't. It entered in like butter or
like a CG effect.
This is the building. Notice it's made
out of layers and layers all the way
from the inside core all the way out.
How in the world could an aluminum and
plastic plane
punch through every layer of that and
pop out the other side
unphased? Like it literally looks the
same as the frames that entered into You
know, he showed frames before it hit the
building and after and they look
identical.
This is what a duck can do to a nose of
a plane.
Notice this says this was an article
that said wrecked. The Airbus 320's
windshield and cone were so severely
damaged during the hail storm over
Eastern Colorado. The plane is pictured
at Denver International Airport where it
made an emergency landing. It had to
make an emergency landing because of
hail. Literally just ice balls falling
from the sky destroyed this plane and
yet we believe that the plane went all
the way through a building of steel and
concrete like butter, popped out the
other side with nose intact.
This was uh
some basketball players took pictures of
a plane that got damaged while they were
like in it and Washington Post said
Thunder players safe after plane has
run-in with a bird. Or was it Superman?
Cuz they're like, man, look at that
damage. It looked like Superman just
punched it in the nose.
But this is just what birds do. Because
the velocity of the plane, the fragility
of the what [clears throat] the plane is
made out of, it cannot withstand birds,
let alone layers and layers of concrete
and steel. And then what's interesting
is when you look at the exit hole.
Notice we we saw the nose pop out right
here, right? The picture shows it
popping out, but this is the exit hole
with beams still intact.
How does
how does a plane pop out
and the beams are still intact? Did it
come out like grated cheese on the other
side?
Like come on, we have to ask questions.
Don't let people make you feel crazy for
asking questions.
Don't let people make you feel like
you're insensitive or some conspiracy
theorist just because you look at a
tragic event and you say, wait a minute,
this doesn't line up. This is this is
journalism. This is like rational
logical thinking.
We need to do that. When we went to
school, you you would do something and
there was like a question at the end
that said critical thinking. Yet now
we're told don't think. Shut your brain
off and believe what the TV says. Here,
take some medication and and stay doped
up on weed because now weed is legal and
alcohol. We want you to just stay doped
up and just believe the media, believe
the fear and just buy into it all and
stay in your house and mask up because
it's scary world out there.
It is a scary world out there. I'm not
going to deny that. But
this is fear propaganda.
Don't be afraid to question.
There was no exit wound.
There are zero broken columns in this
area. Any sort of solid object is ruled
out.
So, here here's a smoking gun.
So, I'm talking about like
how video editing works and all that
because that's how my brain understands
it. I understand it. If I had a handheld
camera and my and my camera's motion is
moving a little bit like this
and I added a smooth flowing plane.
What would happen if I stabilize that
footage? Think about it. There's a
little bit of motion and a smooth plane.
If I took
If I used a program and stabilized the
footage where the footage looks still,
what would that plane be doing now?
That plane would now be matching the
motion of the handheld camera because
now everything is still and so that
smooth flowing plane would now be like
bouncing along.
This is the smoking gun nail in the
coffin you can't deny this stuff. Here
it is.
He took the footage and he stabilized
it.
The top is the handheld camera. Notice
the buildings are drifting and moving
and that
perfectly smooth flowing plane was
added. Now here's the footage that was
stabilized. Notice the buildings are not
moving at all. They're stationary but
everything else seems to be moving
because it's been stabilized. What is
going to happen to that plane now?
The top plane is going to look smooth
because it's it was added
and it's smooth flowing on that handheld
camera.
But now here's the stabilized footage.
Look at the plane.
That plane is jittering and bouncing all
over the place.
You cannot deny this. This is 100%
proof
that at least that footage was
manipulated. You can't deny it. You when
you see that
you can't fake that. You can't
deny it. It was literally faked. That
plane was added later.
So, like I said, this stuff's been going
on for a while. It goes back to the the
moon landing. There was some issues with
what happened in Boston that didn't line
up.
There's all this predictive programming
in The Simpsons and
uh in comic books and movies and
everything. And Ninja Turtles.
So many times these events were put in
there. Even even what happened in
Boston. There's a I have the box set of
Family Matters. If you guys remember
Steve Urkel, I just made reference to
him.
And in a Family Matters episode, Carl
Winslow, the dad, uh was trying to catch
the Boston Marathon bomber. The Boston
bomber.
Predictive programming.
When the pandemic happened, there were
some fishy things that happened in that.
There were There was footage that showed
lines of people waiting to to get seen
in a tent. And yet people were going out
there in New York saying, "There ain't
nobody here. It is a ghost town out
here." He'd walk in the in the
in the hospital and nobody's in there.
And doctors are so bored that they're
dancing and making Tik Tok videos.
But the news was saying, "Look, there's
masses of people out here. This is a
crazy
pandemic going on."
And then there was even footage of
dummies
on gurneys.
Like there were literally I I wish I had
time to add all this stuff. There's so
much out there.
And it's so hard to find now. That's the
thing. It's so hard to find. You got to
look on BitChute. You got to look on
Rumble. But
I remember seeing that they'd show a
hospital room and you just see a plastic
dummy there like
with his mouth open.
And then you'd see footage of of one
hospital and they would say that that
that hospital was at another place, a
different location. They'd show the same
footage and say it was different places.
There's so many reasons why I don't
trust the mainstream media.
And I feel like I have to make a video
like this now because
I mentioned that I believe politics is
like a wrestling match that it's all
staged, that your vote doesn't matter.
That
there are people higher up than the
president that are running the
show.
I noticed this when I was in high
school. I didn't care anything about
politics. I never wanted to vote or
anything. I I wasn't a conspiracy
theorist by any means but I realized
even in high school that no matter who
wins, nothing ever changes. I noticed
that people were Christians and stuff
were saying, "I vote Republican because
I'm anti-abortion." I said, "Guess what?
George Bush is a Republican and
abortion's legal."
Both Bush senior, both
W Bush,
I never saw anything change. So there is
an agenda.
There's a goal that Satan has for this
world and it is to bring about a one
world religion, a one world order, a one
world currency, a new world order. And
that agenda is is playing out before our
very eyes. And what they do is they do
it two steps forward and a one step
back.
So what they do is they'll they'll give
you the illusion of freedom.
Oh yeah, your vote counts. Get out there
and vote. They put all this propaganda
out there. Get out and vote. Because I
know if nobody votes then
they're going to look pretty suspicious
when the next president comes out.
But what they do is it's this pendulum
swing. I've noticed it ever since I was
a kid. The first president I remember
was Bush senior, Republican. Then it was
Bill Clinton, Democrat. Then it was Bush
W, Republican. Then it was Obama,
Democrat. Then it was Trump, Republican.
Notice the pendulum swing. So what
happens is they put somebody in office
that's Democrat. And when as the
Republicans are getting so angry, so
angry, something needs to change. Before
an uprising happens, they say, "Okay,
give them what they want. Give them the
Republican party." And now the
Democrats, they're like, "Well, we lost.
Whatever." And then year after year
they're they're steaming. They're
getting more ticked off and they're
saying right before an uprising happens,
give them Democrat. And it's this
pendulum swing. Nothing changes. Maybe
something changes. That's what I mean by
two steps forward, one step back. So
they're unrolling their agenda. Uh you
know, it's um the Patriot Act. You have
no rights. You get TSA, all this stuff
that happened at 9/11. Then it was the
NDAA Act where you can be
detained for any reason at all. They
don't need any reason. You can be taken
and and taken off to a camp somewhere.
That's real. NDAA, that was signed when
Obama was in.
And they put these things in action and
then if and then two steps forward and
then if we get really mad, they say,
"Okay, we'll take that little thing
back. You guys You guys win." We'll take
one little thing back but they're still
making progress. Two steps forward, one
step back. Pendulum swing. Democrat,
Republican, Democrat, Republican. And so
according to Bible prophecy and what we
understand is coming, a one world
religion.
How can that happen? This
This is what I the majority of the
Christian world misunderstands. I grew
up in non-denominational Christian world
and they are looking for a one man
Antichrist to come on the scene and he's
a president that just hates Christians.
He just hates the Bible and he hates
Christians.
But in reality, the Antichrist is going
to look so much like Christianity that
millions of Christians are going to be
deceived. Do you think Christians are
going to be deceived by a one man who
hates Christians? No. It's going to be
all this coexist. Let's just get along.
Look,
there's the protest is over. There's no
such thing as Protestants and Catholics
anymore. We're all Catholic because
Catholic means universal. We just come
together. Hey, you you believe in Allah
and and Buddha and I believe in Jesus
and look, we all believe in some kind of
faith. Let's just unite. But we can't
just compromise truth. Truth is truth.
99% truth is not truth. So coexist
doesn't work and coexist is what Satan
actually wants. He wants a world where
we all just well, you're you're a little
different than I am but it's okay, you
know. You'll get into heaven.
And so how is this going to come about?
We need
we need a Republican, a very right-wing
Republican leader that's going to say,
"We need to get this country back to
God." Look, all these all these
documentaries are coming out now that
are saying that Nickelodeon and all
these kids um programmings are actually
harming kids. I think that's a great
thing that this stuff's coming out and
being exposed but Jesus said this would
happen, that no secret thing would not
be exposed. And so everything's coming
to light. You got Epstein. You got all
this stuff coming to light and you got
all these um
groups. You know I'm talking about these
minority groups, the alphabet people and
and it's getting worse and worse. You go
to these events and they got kids out
there now and they're
they're throwing money at them like it's
a strip show for kids.
And it's getting the world is getting so
sick that the the population, the masses
are primed and ready for a savior. We
need God. This country needs to get back
to God. And what is Trump saying? Make
America pray again.
Make America pray again. Make is force.
You can't make somebody pray. But that's
his slogan, Make America pray again. And
now how can you get this super
right-wing superhero
into office when so many people seemed
to dislike him and all these celebrities
hated him?
Well, this event made him look like a
Messiah.
Now you got prophets out there saying,
"Yeah, I prophesied this event to a T 3
months ago." And in the prophecy was
that Trump was going to surrender his
life fully to God because he came so
close to death. And now people believe,
"Well, if he wasn't a Christian then he
is now for sure and he's going to save
this country and he's going to make
America great again. He's going to make
America pray again. He's going to bring
this country back to God." And this is
exactly what the Bible says is going to
happen. There's going to be a forced
worship.
There's going to be forced by law. When
you read Revelation, it says that those
who do not worship the beast, which is
the government system and his image,
they will be killed.
And so, we need according to prophecy,
we need some really right-wing person to
get in. And who is that prime candidate?
Right now, I think it's a
a no-brainer who's going to win. I might
be completely wrong, but what I'm saying
is your vote doesn't matter. This has
already been set up from the beginning.
This is prophecy, and we need to start
living like the Bible's real. We need to
start living like Revelation is true and
Jesus is coming soon. And I want to be
ready when he comes. I want my friends
and family to be ready. I want them to
not be deceived. People think this is
like, "Why are you wasting your time
talking about this? Why are you Why are
you talking about what the devil's up
to?" And why? Because I care about
people falling for deception. Do you not
care about people falling for deception?
That's what the Bible's all about. Let
no man deceive you by any means
necessary, even if it means getting on
camera and looking like a fool in some
people's eyes. If I plant a seed in
somebody's mind
to make them start questioning things,
to make them think maybe the Bible's
real. Hey, maybe this guy's onto
something. Or when things start to
happen, they'll say, "Wait a minute, I
heard a guy talking about this."
I heard some guy say that there's going
to be this right-wing dude that's going
to try to force worship.
Let's use this outlet while we can. It's
already being censored like crazy. Watch
your words when you're on here, but put
this stuff out there and warn people.
Jesus is coming soon. I believe it 100%
with all my heart. I just started this
ministry with my wife. We It's called
Candid Truth.
I need your support. We stepped out in
faith so we could help my parents and be
closer to home.
And we just want to get this message out
there. I want to keep putting videos out
like this. Not always like this, but
this was the topic that I thought was
important right now. And when I see this
this guy was shot with a
assault rifle.
His ear is intact. I'm wondering what
this strange shiny capsule-looking thing
is. It might not be nothing, but it does
resemble this blood capsule down here.
What I'm saying is I got questions. Dude
is wearing a bandage on his ear.
And this is This is why I question some
things because all the stuff I was
showing you. If you want to support this
ministry in any kind of way,
we got Cash App, we got Venmo, we got
Zelle. Um
we're working on the website right now.
And I'm going to try my best to get to a
point where I'm putting out multiple
videos a week, reacting,
reviewing, talking about how our how
what's going on in this pop culture,
what's going on in politics, how it
applies to Bible prophecy, where we're
at in Bible prophecy,
and just how close we are to Jesus
coming soon. I believe it with all my
heart.
If you like this video, please give it a
thumbs up. It really helps in the
algorithm. Help this channel grow. Click
a little subscribe action for me. Click
the notification bell and share this
with all your family and friends.
There's going to be more videos coming
out. And I love you. And I thank you for
being here. Thank you for your support.
God bless. We'll see you next time.